let's start with afghanistan you say
it's an unfolding humanitarian disaster
uh
the aid is urgently needed
but i i suppose there will be people
watching this who will say why should we
be giving money to a country controlled
by a murderous regime that's rolling
back human rights especially for women
uh hard won including
by the sacrifice of our own troops
this is a humanitarian catastrophe i
don't
forget the sacrifice of our troops and
part of the reason we were there was to
protect the afghan people
and now we face
a nightmare we face a catastrophe it's
really a moral failure because when
children are starving
and when families are emaciated and when
there is no health provision
and despite polio cholera and covid i
think we've got a duty to act now there
are self-interested reasons for acting
we want to prevent terrorists gaining
the upper hand again and exporting the
terrorism to the west
we want prevent heroin getting to the
streets of britain we also want to
prevent mass migration and already three
million have left afghanistan
but as ron williams and i said in an
article yesterday there is also a duty
to help children in particular and
families with this immediate threat of
starvation itself and this is a matter
of days uh not weeks and months if we
cannot get aid to people they will die
in front of our eyes and we've already
seen tv uh pictures of children so
emaciated that they will not survive so
it's humanitarian and i don't think
anybody any father any mother in the
world would say that when children are
in this difficulty we should fail to act
what we've got to do is find a way
around this that does not legitimize the
regime that gives them no credibility
for the aid that we're giving gets the
money through the ngos and through the
united nations organizations and make
sure it's absolutely clear that the help
is being provided by people who have
wanted to help the people of afghanistan
over the last 20 years
i'm sure a powerful case can be made
morally for this but you yourself have
just raised the point uh when you talked
about getting the money to ngos how can
we be sure that that money is going to
get
to the places where it's needed
and where people can be fed and
sheltered and kept safe over winter
well i'm already chairman of the
education cannot wait organization that
helps refugees and displaced people
and you are able and unicef is being
able to do this to make informal
arrangements at a local level uh where
you can pay the salaries of teachers and
health workers and at the same time make
sure girls can go to school and make
sure that people are actually fed so
there are ways at the moment martin
griffis the humanitarian coordinator for
the united nations is showing that
through the united nations the world
bank and through many ngos we can
actually get aid to people the problem
is
uh that there is an appeal now for four
and a half billion dollars
that's urgently needed for the 23
million people that you talked about to
prevent them starving and only a quarter
of that money has been raised now there
were 40 countries in the coalition in
afghanistan
what i'm suggesting and there is a
petition now circulating through save
the children asking the british public
to support this what i'm suggesting is
that britain and the european union call
a humanitarian conference bring the 40
countries together get the money in make
sure it's actually going to the starving
children and to the families in need but
all that can be done but the money has
not been raised
and one of the reasons i'm making this
appeal this morning with the churches
and faith groups who've signed a letter
also
is that i believe the british public can
ask the government to pay attention to
this call the conference get this done
and of course there are talks starting
with the taliban in norway today and
first on the agenda will be this issue
of humanitarian aid getting through
without giving credibility to the regime
itself
you um of course are able to make this
appeal because you've been for many
years
amongst world leaders and you've been at
all of the conferences and talks and so
on and so forth um
the big issue that would occupy those
conversations today of course is ukraine
um
do you actually think anything is going
to come from the talks with vladimir
putin about ukraine
well let me say first of all the same
principle applies to afghanistan as as
ukraine you do need leadership you need
people to act together you do need unity
and one of the problems in afghanistan
is we need a country to lead this
humanitarian effort and to call the
conference
i think the same applies in ukraine
president putin will exploit any
weakness
any failure to show strength and in
particular any failure to show unity uh
will give
a blank check if you like
to continued aggression
now we know that the demands he's making
are completely unreasonable he wants to
remove weapons from members of nato's
soils he wants to prevent sweden and
finland ever join ever joining nato uh
he wants uh the
nato countries to say that they will not
enlist any countries in the future now
he's making unreasonable demands and of
course the only way to deal with that
because if you exceed to one you'll
simply get another set of demands on top
of them
is to show strength and that's why
i think what emily thornbe said this
morning is really important that you've
got to have a united west and a united
set of allies
and of course that is something that is
in question this weekend and again i
think britain america and the western
allies have got to come together and
show that they are completely agreed on
the need for sanctions that they will be
financial they'll be economic they'll be
targeted on individual uh people
we will not hesitate to apply them
quickly
and i think that message has got to go
out without any uh danger that there is
not unanimity
paul volcker the senior american
diplomat who i'm pretty sure you will
know said last week that that
program that you've just outlined would
be the right thing to do but even so he
did not think
that it would prevent
a russian invasion because if that's
what mr putin wants to do that's what he
wants to do it's what he will do and
nothing we can do can stop him
well you know we know that president
putin wants to declare a sphere of
influence that extends way beyond the
borders of russia itself we know you he
would prefer to have a different
government in ukraine one that is
in his own hands although i'm not sure
about all this information this morning
about uh the particular names
they don't seem to add up
uh but
the important thing is that he i i've
met him on a number occasions i've dealt
with him i've had to stand up to him
when we had the assassination on british
soil
but he's an opportunist he probably does
not himself know what he's going to do
next we know what he wants to do the
question is what he will do the
important thing is at this particular
point in time and there's going to be
discussions the defense secretary is
going to moscow there's letters
exchanging between america and the um
the russians at this point we've got to
show strength and that's i think what
was
uh something of
an issue in the last few days when it
wasn't clear what the germans were doing
the french were talking about a separate
or appear to be talking about a separate
deal that was a european deal with
russia and of course uh there is this
issue about energy prices and what is
actually going to happen if the flow of
gas continues to slow to the west uh all
these issues are going to be taken into
account but the important thing you said
got to have a show of strength you you
said you weren't that sure about the uh
intelligence which has been published
today do you think the foreign office is
um i mean it's very unusual for the
foreign office to publish this kind of
of intelligence do you think they've
overstepped the mark here
well i've no doubt that uh president
putin would prefer to establish a friend
of his as he had before in control in
ukraine and i've no doubt that he has
possible people in mind if he was ever
to be in this position
but the names that have been given don't
necessarily seem to add up
but that's not the real issue the real
issue
is can you get the allies together
can nato uh show its uh power and its
strength as a unified uh force
uh and can we force uh uh the russians
to back down and i think um
you know from my knowledge of president
uh putin he's an adventurist as well as
an opportunist uh but you must not give
him an inch if you're going to stand up
to russian aggression
okay but by my reckoning gordon brown i
don't think there's anybody who has been
in
downing street alive longer than you
have as chancellor and then prime
minister um
what do you make of the chaos that is
engulfing downing street right now and
um can you imagine the kind of thing
that we are reading about taking place
on your watch
well
this is indeed about standards in public
life look we we know the government is
immobilized and despite what dominic rob
says the attention that is needed for
the cost of living crisis
for the schools for people to catch up
as children in schools
for obviously afghanistan for ukraine
for all the problems that are besetting
the health service
the attention has veered uh towards
dealing with these particular scandals
and my fear is that scandal is going to
follow boris johnson as long as he's
prime minister
you know we don't just have the scandal
and all the details will probably come
out later this this week about partying
we have the conflicts of interest we
have the
dubious appointments we have foreign
money and question marks over that who's
paying the bills for what and i don't
think we're going to see this
administration end in anything other
than scandal
are you saying to me that you think
looking at the current prime minister
that this is not a man with either the
character or the moral stature
to occupy
the position of prime minister of this
country
i i think it's about standards in public
life i'm not going to comment on
boris johnson as an individual but but
it is about standards in public life and
the minute the public realize
that governments are asking
uh their
citizens to follow rules that they're
not prepared to follow themselves
and the minute you have a question mark
over behavior and conduct in in public
life that is indeed very serious because
when you're dealing with a pandemic and
now with an economic cost of livings
crisis the most important thing you need
is that people are prepared to trust the
leaders to get things right and trust
them to do things even when they're
unpopular
to get the right uh answers in the long
run so this is really an ethical issue
it's about the conduct of public life
having said that the phrase that is
going around this week is
fish rots from the head
very many people have said this is not
for me to make a judgment
many people have said that this kind of
thing would never have happened with
theresa may david cameron
tony blair
or gordon brown in number 10 because you
set
an example
do you think
that it is time for mr johnson if that
is true
to go
and to have someone who will set the
right standards and the right kind of
leadership both of which you've
mentioned this morning
well trevor you know i came on to talk
about afghanistan and about uh
humanitarian policies and i feel that
boris johnson should be dealing with us
and i i don't want to make this simply
about a person i think it's the
character of the government that is at
issue it's the standards in public life
and if i were him i would be sure to say
that we're going to have a massive
uh review of all rules governing uh
public life in this country because
clearly you cannot run downing street
the way it's been run
you cannot make appointments in the way
they've been made
and you cannot allow the sort of
behavior that is that has happened and
hope somehow the public will not notice
when you're asking them to take
decisions that you're not prepared to
take
themselves look sue grey has got a
report on the the present uh issues
all right you're quite you're quite
right to say let's let's focus on the
things that matter and if i before i let
you go can i just ask you one specific
thing which probably you would know
about better than anybody else in the
world you were the last person to hike
national insurance do you think that
chancellor should go ahead with that or
should it be delayed as
many people are suggesting
well i'm not convinced that national
insurance is the right uh tax to deal
with the problems that we're facing
social care in particular
and i think kyosama is right you've got
to look at people's standards of living
as a whole and what costs they're going
to have to bear
i'm a patron of a charity in fife and
we're dealing with poverty that i have
not seen in my lifetime
we're dealing with people who can't heat
their homes we're dealing with children
who are not going to school well clad
and going to school hungry
and we're dealing with a crisis among so
many people because they are demoralized
and facing mental health problems as a
result of what has happened as a result
of this crisis now to impose upon those
families
an energy price rise in the heating
bills and in their electricity
then to impose a tax rise for those who
are paying
national insurance
at a time when food prices are also
rising at the same time and you've had
this 20 pounds cut in people's universal
credit it is simply not acceptable
and the the devastating effect on
poverty it will be seen very quickly if
all these things go ahead so kierstama
has been right to say we've got to focus
on what the living standards are of
people at the moment and how they're
going to be cut if we don't act